bienvenue à paroles autochtone c'est
melissa maulin depuis cette semaine j'ai
reçu une question de sheldon et de sa
classe de quatrième année à l'école tu
es wasquehal quoi y gagne c'est mon
école où j'ai étudié quand j'étais petit
et sheldon me demande pourquoi est ce
que les
la chasse est ainsi important pour les
autochtones je donne une très bonne
question je pense qu'on chasse est pas
uniquement parce que c'était le plaisir
ou le l'envi de tuer l'animal
c'était vraiment que on s'est adapté au
territoire auquel on habitait si tu vas
dans le grand nord tu peux voir qu'une
impossibilité de faire pousser des
légumes du maïs de la courge des
haricots
alors que si tu viens plus dans la
région de montréal c'était souvent la
source alimentaire la plus importante
accompagné avec du poisson du chevreuil
donc on mangeait vraiment ce qui était
sur le territoire qu'on habitait comme
nous on désigne ce qu'on pouvait
accueillir était quand même très limité
aux petits fruits
mais ce qu'on pouvait chasser c'était le
caribou c'était le castor le parquet
paix que pékin toutes les animaux
n'étaient pas non plus des animaux pour
être mangé des animaux qui étaient
utilisés pour s'habiller pour se
protéger contre le froid
mais chaque animal par exemple faisait
partie d'un écosystème très fragile donc
on faisait extrêmement attention ne pas
surcharger
on chassait à certaines saisons pros
laisser l'animal tranquille quand se
reproduisait des fois l'animal ne se
présentait pas non plus
toute l'année je pense que présentement
comme on est au printemps on sait que
c'est la période des outardes et cana
alors il y avait des cycles aussi à la
chasse pour donner une chance à un
animal de de revenir en force à chaque
année et pour nous de pouvoir se nourrir
avec l'arrivée des européens sont venus
la farine les fruits les légumes et bien
sûr aujourd'hui avec les transports avec
le pétrole
on peut avoir de l'alimentation beaucoup
plus variés
cependant dans un principe d'écologie on
favorisera toujours l'économie et je
tirais la nourriture locale parce
qu'elle demande beaucoup moins
écologiquement et elle est beaucoup plus
proche de ce que on avait besoin
je pense qu'on a vu au cours des
dernières années que manger la
nourriture uniquement qui vient du
magasin peut nous rendre malade parce
qu'on a beaucoup de diabète beaucoup de
maladies du coeur et au fait qu'on mange
des aliments qui était pas les nôtres et
le fait qu on allait chercher notre
nourriture nous garder en forme aussi
donc ce sont des pratiques qui sont
encore excellente pour nous selon le
territoire auquel on habite et mais si
on les fait d'une façon raisonnable et
en respect avec nos traditions pour
justement garder cet équilibre là
merci beaucoup chef d'une porte en
question j'espère que vous avez aimé la
réponse que vous avez nous envoyer des
questions encore et je souhaite une très
bonne semaine et ce parce autochtone